half the reason i did this interview was
i could just ask one question
which is uh what do i need to do to get
you to make another movie
yeah i don't know send me some
send me some good material i've been
going through a lot of stuff
and and um
you know look i wish i'd directed this
movie high ground i would love to have
had a crack at this story
but stephen did a lovely job um i'm
happy with the way the film turned out
but
look i'm i'm looking i'm looking for
stuff actively
you know i've had a couple of things up
and ready to go but then the world
became a bit
strange um to say the least and
you know i'm just here in sydney at the
moment just uh trying to
um keep myself occupied i have a lot of
questions for you
um what tv series would you love to
guest star on
i don't know i i heard they were doing a
sex in the city the other day and i
thought oh that'd be fun to pop up in
that
a lot of people when i speak to them
they mentioned succession
i enjoy watching that show it'd be a
very different experience
to watch that show after you've been on
it you know and it'd probably just be my
ego that would want me to go and be on
succession because it's
such a love show um but i think i
i love watching it i like being an
audience member in natchez it's so well
done
completely what movie or movies do you
think you've seen the most
um hmm i've seen apocalypse now a lot
uh i have seen the graduate
a lot um cooker's nest i've seen
a lot i've watched rolling thunder
review
like three times
i watched it again the other night i
don't know
don't i just love all that footage i
just like all those moments i love that
you know once i read about how you know
what scorsese was doing with it
um i've watched uh
i've watched um king of comedy a lot of
times as well
it's kind of good it's pretty great
uh very good it's pretty fantastic in
fact i think i think the joker owes a
lot to that film
um like the whole story pretty much
um anyway uh not that the joker was not
a great film
um i think that's it i think there's
probably one oh
there's a couple of truffaut films that
i've watched a number of times the woman
next door i've seen a lot
if you could get the financing for
anything tomorrow
what would you make and why you know i
i'd like to see kind of
you remember the candidate i'd like to
see a story about
someone getting into politics these days
like a real kind of insider's view of
what
um what it's like the difference between
you know i've
i've been following politics in
australia uh
since i've been back here and i've been
down to parliament house a couple of
times
for different you know campaigning for
different things and
um i just just just the psychology
behind
going into politics now and and you know
because it feels to me like there's so
many people involved in politics where
i don't really understand where they
stand at all
politically or or ethically or morally
um but there's just such a balance of
of you know um uh working up the ladder
and you know and and playing playing
safe bets here and there where you can't
be pegged
into into a whole which seems to me
is kind of counter-intuitive to the
whole notion of politics
where you actually stand for something
and believe in something so um
i i used to i had the same notion years
ago i was con i was
fascinated by the idea of um
who who now signs up to become a
catholic priest
you know who goes into a ceremony
seminary not
you know what we all know about you know
the the the
the the dangers and the pitfalls of
being um
a priest um who who are those who are
those young
men that decide that they want to go
into the seminary
uh and what is it that drives them is it
the opportunity of having a lot you know
having having a career somewhere where
you have a voice and you're heard
potentially or is it because you you you
really truly
believe that you were led by a higher
power and it's kind of similar with
politics
not to not to sort of mix church and
state but
that they kind of exist in a similar
sort of a realm are you going into it
because
you you want a soapbox and you're driven
by that
by the notion of that having that kind
of influence and that kind of power
or because there's so much
politicking in the in the in the in the
modern sense of the word
involved in in that business um
but it's hard to actually get anything
done or and it's really hard to really
believe
in something you know the system that we
have in australia here we have a
basically have a sort of a two-party
system
we have a coalition government which is
a liberal party in the national party
and it's
the liberal party is more the
conservative party
relative to in the states the liberal
party is the
uh you know the democrats are the less
conservative more liberal
so it's slightly reversed and our
uh our our labour party is the more
is the more um sort of broader-minded
uh liberal thinking it's so yeah because
when i think of it i think
it would be the complete opposite
so i i know i've been interested in that
you know there's so many politicians
that
that that that probably
sit right on the fence but they know
that they could go further
uh you know with the republican party
than they could have with the democratic
party
you know um yeah i don't know i don't
know how it is in australia but
uh politics here in the united states is
off the rails
it's it's a really bad time and uh it's
just a really bad time
one thing that always gets forgotten and
i think and i think um
is really interesting is that they are
elected public
servants their role is to represent the
people
and that somewhere gets lost and i think
i think media has
has to take responsibility for that in a
large degree because we we
you know we've turned it in america
certainly it's been turned into uh
i say we because i'm a dual citizen i'm
an american citizen as well as an
australian citizen but
i think um we have uh held them up with
um that kind of um overt
media attention um but i still believe
i still believe that there are
politicians out there
um that believe in something and fight
for a cause and
and and want to follow that through and
i just hope that that at a certain point
they're going to outnumber those that
are more opportunistic i
pray you're right i really mean that i
want to jump into films for a second um
what do you remember about making la
confidential because i absolutely
love that movie and you have your that's
like one of your first
film roles i believe it was my first
film yeah
i mean it was great it was fantastic
dante spanotti
shot the thing curtis hansen was lovely
and gentle and warm
um yeah it was
it was an unreal experience i can't you
know i can't
um i do remember this
is that you know because i auditioned
for the ed exley character that guy
pierce played
and i came you know i was told that i
came very close
and when i found out that um
you know they'd cast someone else i'd
lost someone else i had no idea who it
was
and then when i found out it was guy
pierce it was another australian i was
like
what uh you know i was kind of
disappointed i mean guy was incredibly
he was brilliant in that role but i was
like i mean you know if i'd lost
sean penn or someone i could have i i
probably would have stomached it a
little better but i lost it to guy
pierce who's
who was sort of fresh off the boat as
well i was like what
anyway no disrespecting guy i mean he's
a wonderful
is it he's a very talented actor i
totally get what you mean
and i'm sure guy would understand um i
really dig the movie margin call
and you have a small but important part
in that film
and it's a murderer's row of talent in
that thing
uh same question what do you remember
about making that much
it was it was fantastic making that film
not just because
you know the cut the cast was incredible
and everyone got along
very well uh and there was a real nice
ease
um it was a very small budget
we we had the floor of um i think it was
a
i think it was the whole floor
pen plaza or something on the 36th floor
so you know the view was incredible and
that was basically where the majority of
the film
almost all of the film was shot there in
those trading rooms
and it was a hedge fund firm that had
gone out of business
and they and and we just moved in and we
all had an office which is basically a
your own change room uh and then you'd
go to the set on the other side and then
you know the floor above was where they
had catering so
it was it was hermetically sealed uh
so we were around each other all the
time and it was it was yeah it was a
really good experience
i mean jc chandra did such a great job
with that film
for his first film um
he he just made it very simply it wasn't
complicated didn't
he didn't try to overcomplicate it uh
and yeah like you said it was it was
an incredibly talented cast and it was
in a hiatus from the show i was on the
tv show
and it was in a hiatus and one thing i
really loved about it it was a really
short shoot so it didn't take up the
whole hiatus i could still have a
holiday
yeah i think people don't don't realize
uh when you're making a show
and that you're talking about mentalist
i believe when you're making a show like
that
it takes up so much of your calendar
that when you finally have a break
it's you know it's it's um it's a very
it's like
a summer vacation you have to be very
selective with what you want to do
yeah i actually had to get talked into
that because i was on a holiday
i was in the uk actually touring
universities with my
my daughter at the time does it ever get
old people asking you about devil wears
prada or is it one of those things where
it's like
so beloved that you're like i i love
that i'm in
i've never seen it um wait for real
i've never seen it wow yeah
i kind of get it i saw the trailer um
and i think the movie was a really good
movie and it was very successful and
and uh i can generally like you know
it's funny like after you've worked for
a number of years you can
kind of you know i i never achieved
i was never like a movie star i never
really achieved
this great uh and you know i had success
what i would constitute
what i would uh attribute to as success
um but uh
the films that i've done are quite
varied
and i can generally pick like oh that's
a devil where's prada
fan when someone comes up and goes oh hi
and it's like devil where's prada fan
um yeah so that that that's interesting
i don't know yeah it's good i don't i i
don't
as long as people are courteous and
polite i i i
it makes me feel good to make someone
feel good so um
if people enjoy it then that's great i
think into why i actually get to talk to
you and i
thank you for indulging me with
everything else what was it about this
material
and this project that said i i need to
do this
first of all because i'd not seen a film
like this
um i thought it was ambitious in what it
was
actually trying to set out to do um and
do it in a way where
it was still kind of like a you know an
exciting film
and uh
i had moved back to australia when i
when i made breath and i
and i'd gotten um and i was curious
about
sort of the development of um
the in the indigenous story story in
australian
cinema um and how how it was represented
and there's a few phenomenal indigenous
directors making
their stories uh in different ways i had
not seen this story
done in this particular way with
language
and you know seeing indigenous
australians with an
organized resistance to um
and if you know fighting back in the way
that they that they did
in this film i felt that that it was
that had the potential to be very
empowering uh but also had the potential
to um awaken a lot of white australians
to
some of the the to sit with some of the
real truths
that that
took place the atrocities that took
place in the colonisation of this of
this country
and also
touches on some of the beauty and the
richness of the indigenous
indigenous culture as it exists and has
existed for sixty thousand
60 000 years um
yeah and and you know like anything it's
like
i knew it was going to be a really
difficult film to make a really
challenging film to make
um and uh i i also knew that even if the
film didn't turn out it would be an
experience that would be incredibly rich
and um would help
me develop uh as a human being
and um give me a broader understanding
of
of um of
of of what happened here in this country
and i think it's happened similar things
have happened in in in
obviously in a lot of countries that
have been colonized
in your country as well i saw so many
similarities
uh between the native americans in
america and what happened in australia
and to be honest i didn't really know
that much about the australian history
but i felt like i learned a lot watching
it i thought the movie was very well
done
do you feel that you know a lot about uh
you know
american indian history yeah i i've
studied that myself because i think it's
important to be educated to your own
you know the history of a country for me
i also
like that story the story in high ground
like that story i
i didn't learn anything about that in in
school
that wasn't taught that wasn't the his
history of uh
the history of australia um
that i was taught in school was was all
based around captain cook
and you know turning
essentially turning what was a sort of a
wild frontier
into uh you know a white colonized
society one of the things i think that i
commend you on about making this movie
is
a story like this in a movie like this
you know people aren't clamoring to tell
these stories these are really hard to
get made
and i'm curious can you sort of talk
about you know
the fact that these are these are very
difficult stories to bring to life
and um that aspect of it you know the
film industry is this is this sort of
hybrid between
between art and commerce and you know
and in the art
of it uh you know art can be sometimes
confronting and revealing
and um you know uh challenging
um but obviously
commerce drives a lot of a lot of it we
are
fortunately in a time where we are
embracing
major changes where we're not looking
we're not not
everything is not completely whitewashed
anymore
we're curious and interested in
different cultures
um it you know even within our societies
and i think that's
that's a beautiful fantastic development
for
uh all of us as a community
but all of us as artists as well to to
be able to explore these different
stories
yes it's not easy to make a film like
this because
a a lot of our base entertainment is
is um you know good
good versus bad it's more polarized um
so it's nice to it's nice to have a film
that sits
somewhere in in the middle and it deals
with this sort of gray areas
you know um it is my character
a white savior
he's ambiguous at times everyone is
ambiguous
he's probably more ambiguous than other
characters um
avoiding the polarization i think is
interesting
you know also like uh you know
to bring this story in australia to
bring this story
to white australians uh is is a
is a great service to be able to do that
for them to look in and to be confronted
and to be challenged and
quite honestly i i've watched the film
in the northern territory community
screenings indigenous community
screenings
and their experience of the film is one
thing uh
and obviously i've talked to white
australians that have seen the film
who immensely enjoyed the film and feel
that
it is every australian's obligation to
the to their country to go and see this
film and to experience that
but incredibly challenged uh and
feel um incredibly uncomfortable in a
lot of scenes in the film and i say
that's fantastic sit with that
uncomfortability there's nothing
wrong with feeling uncomfortable uh it's
it happened it happened on
many occasions and and what you're
seeing on screen is probably a
a a very very diluted watered-down
version
of how atrocious it was
so sit with it um don't don't don't run
from it
um just be there
and and feel it and and let that go into
you
and and resonate within you um because
it's gonna help it's gonna it's gonna
shift
it'll help shift the needle for you for
everyone
and and i think that's what we're trying
to do now is shift the needle
you know there's obviously people that
are gonna be flying on that
on the bull bar of that needle and
they're gonna shift that quickly and
they wanna shift that
and they stand and they can stand there
and go why aren't you all over here
it just does take a little bit of time
um
and i understand in patience but i also
some people
need to sit with the uncomfortability of
it and and
and i think uh that's what a lot of
people are trying to avoid they're
trying to avoid being uncomfortable
art can do that a hundred percent and no
this is uh everything you said i agree
with um my last thing for you because
i'm basically out of time
i'm just curious uh if you think i think
one of the strengths
of what's going on with streaming is
that it is
not it is not forced to be a four
quadrant
project you can be aiming at you know
individuals or smaller groups of people
and i think that's allowing more voices
to be uh heard um and it's allowing for
more diversity both in front of and
behind the camera
i'm just curious if you could talk about
your take on streaming um
if it's something that you are you know
what i mean just like how it's just
bringing in a lot of people
uh to tell their story i think
uh i i would agree with you you know i
mean
it's it's uh more and more so it's
becoming a portal to
the world where you can go
um and explore different cultures uh and
and and see um
um different perspectives and different
views
of things other than your own and and i
think that's
that is a great blessing it's kind of
like the it's kind of like the
decentralization of it
you know it's like the um
uh it's opening up these great windows
we used to have this
this um this kids show in australia
still exists it's called play school
and they had a section where they went
to the windows uh and they'd look
through the windows and they'd have
these little video clips where they take
you into these sort of
different worlds like oh and this is the
this is the life of a um
um a dairy farmer uh as a kid and you'd
watch it
uh and this is the life of uh you know
so i see netflix now when i turn it on
or any of these streaming services it is
there's all these different windows that
you can go down
um and explore um
and it's it's it's good i mean for a
long time it's like
you know most of the television i watch
is is
foreign because i'm just curious as the
way they tell stories
um and if it's very good america will
generally try to buy the right sort and
remake it anyway
it's true unfortunately
it's very true um i listen i gotta go uh
a million other questions but i'll save
those for the next time i talk to you
for
the movie that you directed hopefully
yeah okay i'm gonna get i gotta get off
my ass and get on with it you're right
listen you made a really effing good
movie
and i'm just saying you should do
another one you know what's the
you know anyway that's just me being
selfish i guess there's a lot of great
movies being made there's a lot of
people that
are getting opportunities now that that
you know probably didn't have the chance
uh earlier uh to have opportunities and
i think it's
this great stuff out there i'll i'll get
i'll get back in the queue at some point
stay safe and healthy thank you so much
for giving me your time
thanks take care